I'm joint joined today by Joel Whitney
who is the author of Fink's how the CIA
tricked the world's best writers Joel
this is a particular interest now in a
world of swirling fake news accusations
different levels of trust of American
intelligence agencies as we're seeing
through the Donald Trump a transition
team with regard to Russian hacking and
CIA and FBI reports and your book
focuses on the CIA and writers that many
of us have have at least heard of if not
read so talk to us first about what
writers we're talking about and also
what you're talking about when you say
the CIA tricking these writers yeah well
first of all thanks for having me on the
show ya some friends have made some
comments about the timing of the book
and it does seem accidentally lucky in
some ways but also very unlucky in other
ways that we're dealing with so much
possible distorted information the
writers were part of a CIA plan that was
attempting to just show our European
allies that we had high culture here in
the United States we weren't just a
country of tanks and Cadillacs and
hamburgers we also had the great
Hemingway Faulkner a lot of these
writers that I talked about of the book
were just doing their job and they were
brought into some magazines that were
launched by the CIA to make sure that we
were the United States is competing with
what were presumed to be Soviet
propaganda and cultural propaganda
outlets in various countries around the
world so talk about how this worked it
would be great to dig into the magazines
that you're referring to we could use
the Hemingway example I know that also
in the book you talk about it not
American writer a Colombian writer uh
who wrote 100 years of solitude Marquez
at whichever one you want to sort of
start with and tell us how it all worked
well it worked in a number of ways but
in the early 50s the magazines that were
created by the CIA
were I think rightly described and seen
as quite reputable they were in fact
forums that had a diversity of opinion
and so if somebody like Hemingway
Faulkner were to consider one of these
magazines and it was pointed out to me
recently in one of the reviews of my
books that the Falkirk contributed
directly to the London magazine
encounter so these are some magazines
with a lot of diversity of opinion they
publish great writers that's always been
the story that's gone out and as the
fastest of program continued it seemed
like the rumors about the paymaster's
behind these magazines was making it a
little bit harder for them to do their
work because I guess the basic notion
was the soviet union funds culture does
it openly and sometimes it presides over
the cultural creators with a
sledgehammer that was true they were
bullied to a lot of their artists in the
Soviet Union so the idea was we could do
it more subtly and that led to it being
secret so in the beginning you know I
look at how the paris review was sort of
a sibling to these official magazines
and how an interview with the charity
which was seen widely as being an aid
political magazine could have led your
mat your interview if you were a leftist
like Hemingway or if you were a
political regardless it would have been
syndicated into the CIA's official
magazines now that's not in itself a big
deal but it needs to a friendly kind of
rapport between the two organizations
the paris review and organizations like
it with the CIA's cultural propaganda
part which is called the college total
freedom once again so with in the case
of the purse review it led them to
sharing a staffer so this staffer would
have been looking for those great
interviews and turning them right over
and getting them translated into the
outlets of the CIA's intellectual work
in places like Japan Germany France all
over the world as the as the program
becomes more sort of
on the open end of open secrecy a lot of
the leftists that they thought to have
debates with would not participate so
what they did was they got some of these
guys through friendships through social
networks in the old tubs of the meaning
into the magazine for their creative
work so garcia marquez the great
colombian writer goes on to win the
Nobel he gets sucked into this magazine
called moon geun well no wonder no evil
looks like a great magazine it is by all
measures a great magazine but it happens
to be funded by the CIA at that point in
his career he was a little bit older
he's pushing 40 versity markets doesn't
have anything to do with the CIA so the
secrecy enables him to who get roped
into excerpting two chapters from his
masterpiece 100 years of solitude in a
tiny little archive in Princeton I found
his response to his editor which
essentially said I will never contribute
again and by the way I feel like we're a
pair of chuckles kind of brought
together by the CIA but no one was one
question I have about that is so
initially the writers and maybe the
answer is different for different
writers initially the writers did not
know that these publications were were
affiliated with the CIA but ultimately
they found out am i understanding that
correctly I think it's a case by case
thing you have to look at and that's why
it's good to be diligent and read the
biography someone like a writer called
Dwight MacDonald you know he always said
that he didn't know but there was one
piece of his that made him suspicious
because it was censored if you look case
by case there are theories some of them
supposition about who knew what when
that's what people became obsessed with
when this program was outed in 1957 now
i show that Plimpton George Plimpton the
editor of the curse of you probably knew
that the Congress was getting its money
from the US state whether he knew the
CIA or not not totally clear but he knew
that before the revelations came out and
that matters because it shows on one
level if you're in favor of this program
which was patriotism if you're against
it it shows that he was willing to
tolerate a little bit of secrecy to beat
the Soviets and to co-fund Paris editor
at the time in the late fifties early
sixties so you
I never have to ask case by case even
Garcia Marquez said that when he was
contributing he knew the rooms in the
mid-sixties by then it would have been
in places that were anti-imperialist
like Latin America where there's been a
revolution in Cuba after so much you
know bullying by the United States at
the foreign policy level they were
suspicious in some cases much earlier
the leftists tended to know some of the
people who participated like Nelson
Aldrich at the paris review he was that
he was the hinge between the paris
review and the congress for cultural
freedom and he said there were open
secrets and open rumors and that he
didn't know but he effectively believed
that it was a CIA program and so as it's
getting ready to be exposed in 56 7 I
feel like those rumors grew in intensity
there's some interesting sort of
subtlety to some of these examples in
the sense that I mean for example to
take the moon the nuevo example uh
generally considered sort of like a
moderate left perspective and you might
say well the CIA is not necessarily that
known for being moderate left although I
guess the political leanings of the CIA
or least the perception of those uh
leanings has shifted over time but you
might say well why what's the interest
of the CIA in being involved with a
moderate left perspective and the
context was well you had the Cuban
Revolution which was seen as a radical
left perspective so comparatively it was
quite moderate to support a moderate
left perspective and to me that signals
a sort of subtle understanding from the
CIA that maybe not everybody attributes
to it yeah I think that's fair and I
think some of my peers in the study of
the so-called cultural Cold War have
insisted on that and pointed that out
not everybody the CIA saw highway number
one a lot of the people who work with
them were not CIA agents per se but
collaborators too and some of them were
were famously libo and even socialist
like norman thomas the co-founder of the
aclu was a collaborator on a predecessor
to mundo nuevo called combat day and
basically because there were a lot of
people who you know very much believed
in ideals that we do associate with the
United States and our founding documents
but we don't so much associate with the
CIA there was a diversity of opinion but
you put your finger on the main thing
that I wanted to explore which is if
someone is of the revolutionary left
they're not going to read blunt
anti-communism that sounds like a
relatively centrist or people in
reaction exposition on some of these
questions without imperialism about the
world United States in the world so you
know a liberal left perspective would
have seemed like a way to bring them
back and I think that's what mundo the
way of what was doing I describe it it's
just two left enough and I say that just
two left enough to engage the people who
are in favor of the Cuban Revolution
boom they were trying to orchestrate a
debate which I admire that debate I
admire that's any debate that brings
socialists in conversation with liberals
it was the secrecy I think that made it
troubling and made people like Garcia
Marquez quite angry when they found out
what can we take from the story that you
write about and thinks in terms of its
application to 2017 the incoming
administration trust and distrust of
agencies like the CIA and FBI mean is
there how do you connect the two issues
yeah I mean a couple of things first of
all secrecy tends to lead to a blurring
of our language and of our terminology
so a phrase like packing if I'm going to
examine the usefulness of this idea of
the Russian packing the election right
now I won't know exactly what the
allegations are so far tacky because me
attacking as a metaphor life hack
something so what does that mean if it's
just the allegation that hacking is
actually being used to describe a leak
that I also want to ask where the leaks
truthful or not even if they were unfair
because they've only pertained to one
candidate so some of the questions I
look at our house secrecy leads us to
blur things
way that favor our impulses for our
cookies candidate I think we have to be
I think we have to challenge that I
think we have to look beyond what
interests us at the moment but I'm also
wary to say that because of very
sympathetic of the idea of a very
qualified candidate essentially losing
the elected election perhaps because of
unfair amounts of information about
about her but not her opponent so I'm
i'm sort of agnostic about how much you
can apply what's in my book towards the
situation that we're now but I do see
something that's very troubling starting
in about 2012-2013 michael hastings was
reporting in buzz feed after his famous
rolling stone article right if there was
a campaign to get rid of the rules
against doing propaganda on the united
states whose own population but stuff
that we do abroad was being sought a law
was being overturned to allow us to do
it here and that's what some of this
feels like to me we're now doing blatant
propaganda on our own population between
taxpayer money is paying for us to be
deceived or manipulated or to get loaded
information the book is finks how the
CIA tricked the world's best writers
we've been speaking with the book's
author Joel Whitney Joel thanks so much
for talking to me about this David
thanks for having me on great to talk to
you